Eastern super Blitz it's 90 minutes of
3-0
I think the plan is to play Super
aggressively and to play as many gambits
as possible
and we do have a countdown oh three two
one zero says Gambit that's the plan
okay
first opponent actually playing the
second highest rated player it looks
like
and maybe I'll start with the Budapest
um one of my favorite go-to gambits
uh spent a lot of time preparing this
opening in the past
A3 is almost always met with A5
and I'm going to try and play quickly
try and play
more aggressively than usual like Queen
H4 Queen H3 already
I'm allowing this move
it could get really spicy
okay I should probably Castle
want to play D6 Bishop G4
how are you doing tonight Eric
I'm doing well I'm not asleep yet which
is good I'm winning material too
can't ask for much more
I'm gonna go after this Pawn
Pawn is pinned and kind of backwards
uh light's going after this pond
so probably this move
I want to play C6 soon
now Rook
uh what's the best way to do this
considering B5 go play Rook C7
just want to double up
hello
it's a weirdly annoying move
I play Queen
like a funny response Queen F5 putting
the queen in the face of danger
but the the danger goes in both
directions
hello to kaido's Modern fortune teller
yeah if you're just joining this is the
first game of the Stream
it's super aggressive super Blitz
I used to have like a series on YouTube
basically dedicated to playing these
tournaments and playing Super
aggressively so I might uh
give some new life to the series
if you're watching in the future on
YouTube let me know if you want to see
more of this type of content
yeah so Bishop takes Pawn they take on
E3 and be a fair trade
um foreign
I think I should defend thinking Rook C8
but there's some issues there
well now this calls for positional chess
which
let me try and
show how it's done hey Eric I loved your
reply I always love your content about
all atmosphere slash conversations
especially the quakerful puns all the
love
I appreciate the message
I'm I feel like things have kind of gone
wrong
I have a four though I think A4 will
save me
uh maybe not
now something like this
I gotta move a lot quicker
opponent has compensation
uh yeah that's a move
play like King
King h8 not the prettiest
I just want to lose upon yeah
and then at least white no longer has a
bishop pair there's ideas of F5 there's
ideas with this
it's funny the pawn was pinned and after
Rook here the bishop was pinned
okay Rick F2 coming
still not over
kind of a weird Pawn race
but we'll hopefully see why the Rook
will be more powerful than the bishop
[Music]
still really not so simple
oh snap rosen's wearing the championship
Andrea boeth as aggro hoodie Go full ham
good sir Stafford Gambit for president
and oh yeah greetings from a snowy
Liverpool
warm greetings from Irene St Louis
this is actually a really complex end
game
I'm trying to make sense of
I feel like I've gone terribly wrong
here
I've gone terribly wrong
oh no
component Miss Bishop D3
still not good though
foreign
oh
I think I had a good position
I lost Focus I lost a threat at some
point
what to do
it wasn't caused by the opening
I think it was my lack of uh end game
technique
okay we're starting with uh
this is called the Swiss Gambit or the
arena Gambit right Lucifer scheme
um and then I tilt a little bit
times would be even more aggressive
now playing A Smith Mora Gambit
this is actually actually just posing
into an alapin
um
have this move
a little bit out of theory here but
and still some Central tension Bishop
c4's idea
foreign
lab
I think you Fab dabs
happy two years to fad dabs
yeah so I'm just gameting the pawn
basically
although black probably doesn't want to
take the pawn because the G file would
be pretty valuable
and I might even go for H4 soon
this is a move
start with H4
okay so Queen has to find a square
oh as I keep pushing
you gotta keep pushing
if Knight takes I play Queen B5 and Fork
both nights
let's play this I'm pinning
there's an idea to play D5 take and then
take
yeah so this uh this offers a queen
trade
but thankfully I'm keeping my Bishop
here
black doesn't have time to take because
I take on G5
hey it's me Eric says what's the most
aggressive number
uh
I have to think about that
I feel like 99
just the way that it means no no in
German it's kind of like passive
aggressive
or the more nines the more aggressive
wait where's my meat
I'm sorry it's like
oh it's so close I think I just take on
G7
and this is the most aggressive Rook
sacrifice in the position
the idea is to play Queen G5 and then D5
and then I don't think black has a
defense here
like Bishop S6 can probably be pre-moved
and then Checkmate will come shortly
after
foreign
chat with uh
some aggressive number of suggestions oh
seven eight nine like uh
that what was it
ah nine
things for the 999 bits
hey it's me Eric okay that was a nice uh
a nice rebound after the first game
got the w got some berserking points
oh seven is the most aggressive number
because seven eight nine
or is it the most hungry number
okay
um
44th
playing Andre something something
oh 1777. good afternoon from Singapore
oh good afternoon Singapore backgammon
welcome back
yeah if you're just joining um I'm
committing to play
basically playing gambits and trying to
play Super aggressively
this was in England Gambit kind of
declined
resembles the Budapest structure
uh trade
I really want to play D4
I think I'll start with Queen E7
like D5 D4 is a idea
not seeing how to make it work though
so I'll start with this move
if we trade then I hit the knights
we don't trade I trade the Knight anyway
centralize a queen
okay we have another very sharp position
I mean usually when the King's Castle on
the opposite sides
it guarantees sharpness
and I'm gonna go Full Throttle here
like Queen A5
there's this move too there's also this
move
It's Kind of a Funny move
take first
offering a queen trade
and now Queen A5
okay so I have 38 seconds
so keep in mind I did berserk
like the white king is more of a Target
than my own King
let's move back
this bishop wants to enter the game
as something like D6 and Bishop E6
oh wow so I can take that defends the
bishop and this is still hanging
I have a feeling why it's going to play
this hoping I miss queen G7
but A2 is a much bigger Target here
[Music]
um
okay I'll trade
[Music]
yeah the biggest concern is time
G7 is no longer concerned
I'm trying to make the queen move away
from defending the Rook
not so easy though
or is it easy
Queen C1 I play Rook B1
yeah I think this actually this wins
material the queen is basically trapped
because I'm controlling all these
squares except F6 but then I take the
Rook
uh yeah let's take
13 seconds
this should be enough time
okay
that was a fun game
I got a little bit low on time there
oh thank you Jerry for press
cheering 99 bits
good evening to Grandma said Rune
welcome back good to see you
okay let's make some things up a little
bit I'll still play E4 but um
and try and get a new Gambit here
oh there's a funny line I'm hoping for a
D5 E5 D4 there's a line where we both
make new Queens
D6 is hard to
it's hard to play a Gambit but I'll play
a basically a Grand Prix attack
and Grand Prix isn't really a Gambit but
it's uh it's an aggressive way to play
against what is now a Sicilian
started as an alekine then appearance
and then a Sicilian
a bunch of different openings
mesh together
yeah the idea is to try and break the
center open
and this move aims to make this bishop
happy but also this bishop happier
okay hitting G7 now
oh
and darkspurs are a bit tender
I Really Wanna
yeah I want the Knight involved Rook
wants to be involved
some x-ray vision against F7
I think E5 now
oh that's a good move
um
okay these pawns are both hanging
but
with every Pawn that's lost a new file
is opened
wow
let's take
with every Bishop that's lost
a knight will deliver a fork
so after it takes takes the knight uh
does a lot of damage
and where's my pretty mate
I think I'll just take the pawn
this move might come
and queen of four
just leaving the bishop attacks
wait was that rooking I think the Rook
was just hanging there
I should have taken the rook and not the
pawn
okay Queen B8 looks fun
so hitting the rook and Bishop
well the position look at the pieces all
the pieces are playing some role
Bishop taking away the athlete swear
as Rook as a Sitting Duck so is a bishop
uh there's a meeting one it's made in
one that's me because uh e-file opens so
the bishop is pinned
okay I'll take it
was a fun game
that's three in a row
yeah the only game I lost was the one
game I didn't berserk
so maybe I should keep berserking
I'll keep playing E4
this time I'll play a wing Gambit
already had Smith Mora and Grand Prix
this kind of reminds me of an Evans
Gambit like C3 and D4
very center focused
wow
look at this move
I have to be careful here and there's
some Bishop before
Bishop C4 first
yeah this is not like the traditional
chess or objectively good chess that you
should play
I'm sure if we run the engine on my
play thus far
the stockfish will be very disappointed
in me
but it leads to interesting and very fun
Dynamic positions and that's really the
goal
so I'm down two ponds
but I have a lot of streams left school
let's go
just realize the alert volume might be a
little bit loud
just lowered it a bit
[Music]
um
yeah let's get out of the PIN
thank you funky donkey
Ah that's a good move
hey bishop
get away with this
this is very questionable
I have 37 seconds
okay in focus
I want to take the pawn
wow
secure
I think that's a trade
although there is this move I'm losing
material
unfortunately
oh that's a really good move
um let's play this
A6 is probably coming
I'm trying to create some tricks
yeah I will play
hitting the bishop
so I'm down the piece
you can pre-move this
you can see five good move
so Bishop here I take and then the trade
favors me
I think
Queen E3
Queen C7 rookie eight
I'm still down a piece unfortunately
I'm gonna play this never mind
here's a bishop defense so this isn't a
huge concern
Knight's attached King is kind of open
okay I win back the piece but I'm still
down two Pawns
I don't want a queen trade
also have to be very careful about
running mate and flagging
time scramble time
foreign
move Queen takes B3
okay I didn't deserve to win that but I
played really well that game but somehow
I
I got the dirty flag
not sure if I feel I should feel good
about that
playing a benoni playing a benoni Dutch
I went through a phase of playing this
several years ago
not quite a Gambit but it's just a weird
funny opening
um
play Queen B6
and just a different way of developing
the pieces
G5 Bishop G7 it actually looks very
playable
I have the bishop pair darks for Bishop
is actually going to be very nice
in this sort of structure
okay we could trade Queens
I'll leave the tension
is some kind of a6b5
sometimes the night goes to see Saturn
first
I think coming to D7 should be fine
wow
centralizing the bishop
giving the check
oh I've messed up okay I allowed Knight
B6 there
was a very careless decision
of Playbook B8
there's about four is an idea
um
like to play some kind of like B5
get rid of the knights
Bishop E5 next
so I'm down the pond but it feels like
there's comp
got the Rooks on and two open files
B4 is an idea Fish Bay six is an idea
the king is short on squares actually
some C4 idea
I'm not quite though
hmm
before first
so I'm thinking if C4 I play E6 you know
what they call a win by a dirty flag
what a win a win yeah
that's uh probably a true statement
so I'm just trying to open the position
[Music]
and get the bishop to come alive for 14
months of fun and instructive chess
content my son and I always enjoy your
content I appreciate that you shallow be
oh wow what is this
take
not sure what's going on here
I'm down two Pawns
but I have this move may be coming
good move
another time scramble coming
sagging another Pawn I just want to get
The Bishop's F5
oh no my Pawns
oh
that was careless
if White Flags I went on time
I don't think white realizes that
because the bishop is sufficient meeting
material
yeah that's a really dirty flag
so according to fide rules if
if you have even a bishop
against like a pawn it's there's still
possible mates because the king could
like Corner itself
the bishop in the corner and Bishop you
seven checkmates
um
but that's it's one of like the weird
fide rules on chess.com that would have
been a draw
um
I I have a position not too long ago on
chess.com where my opponent flag to call
the game a draw but I had for his mate I
had like a only a king of knights but
there is force made in the position and
uh the server called it a draw
so okay let's play northoshop
Queen B3
going for another fun Gambit
um this case black did not accept the
gamut
but we're getting uh the classic
orthoslop
French type position
this is playable or rather not self-made
because you have to deliver it but you
need them to put themselves into a bad
position can't force it yeah
[Music]
yeah I would require a lot of self
-help
also what is this position black has two
Center Pawns in my territory this is
already a threat but coming to the
counter
counter pressure the C file
I mean every game I'm getting like
really interesting positions
I'm also getting kind of not great
positions but
at least they're interesting
I want to make use of the C file or the
battery
like the smooth
how to make this work
this first and D3
you can use H4 first
I really wasn't sure what my plan should
be Queen G3 is an idea
probably Queen G3 and go for the king
side attack
E6 might be a threat
I think Bishop G6 was some intention but
then H5 comes
this might be a move
and relax taking time here
wait this move I played this move Rooks
defended
I'm scared about this d-pawn marching
down
the black is also maybe scared let's
play B4
okay H6 should be coming next
but I work on D1 E6 is an idea hey I
think UGM candy
welcome Raiders if you're just joining
I'm like I'm I'm on the verge of
flagging
but super crazy position
[Music]
uh let's take Knight G5
has so many Pawns
just gotta stay calm
the file okay don't Fork me
it's a nasty threat
to play this
oh no
component misses it
component found something though
I am still alive
no Queen trade
okay winning something
I don't know if I want to trade off the
bishop though
okay rook's getting active
King's getting active
G4 may be coming
oops
foreign
there we go okay
a funny game opponent did have a um
a pretty clear win in this position
there is 92 takes on them Bishop E5 if I
were to take back with the PIN
okay I escaped there
in the last three games in a row at
least I've been losing every game I ask
this every month but could you please
say hello to my daughter Mari oh hello
watching your videos
nice to hear happy early birthday
this month
so probably like later
December
I used to be a four-year-old
I was that was about 25 years ago
try and enjoy enjoy the year while it
lasts it's fun being for
okay this is Eric
I was four I didn't know how to play
chess
it's a hard time in my life to remember
okay trying to play
trying to play a staffer gamma here
uh or a reverse fried liver
thank you
this is actually a nice position the
bishop controls darkspace
and Knight tc5 is playable
now it's equal material
it resembles a Stafford actually
it was like Queen Queen G5 visual G4
there's a line Bishop G2 and then Bishop
F3 takes in Queen D2
opponent wants a castle kingside
I don't know if I can stop that
play Queen
I really want to stop it
hmm
I think I'll just play this I'll play
positionally
I am stopping away from castling
that's a move key two coming
okay so I'm I have my usual my usual
time deficit
but I have the bishop hair pretty solid
position Rooks will come to the center
files
it's one of the benefits of not having
any Center Pawns
and the point of having two Center pawns
is I can make use of both files
I want to play C4
maybe C6
maybe this move
start with H5 because I want to attack
the pawn and not allow G4
I think C6 B5
G5
preventing Knight F4
another idea is to push the a pawn
we'll probably see A4
so let's keep pushing pawns here
maybe I'll just try and queen the Apon
the Bishops control so many squares in
the center like this
also controlling the queening swear
I mean let me bring the king in first
oh
[Music]
um
so Knight takes Bishop F4
and this is still a plan
you Rook here first
Rook is generally well placed against uh
or behind the pass Pawn
and C3 does block the diagonal
diagonals out very blocked
but the pawn is so close to queening
and these pieces don't help too much
is still pinned
okay now it's about the g-pawn
foreign
[Music]
okay
okay that was nice game
manage the time indecently there
so
this is really turning into like an
arena Gambit losing the first game
sacrificing the first game
Missouri winning the rest of the games
oh playing D McNally we go way back
we attended chess camp together when we
were small children
I'll play D4
play one of these
and Dan knows uh
maybe knows some Theory here
but this is already a nice line because
the Knight doesn't have a great Square
controlling all these squares
so in IGA there's a choice between this
and this
usually the moves come in combination
there's also this move which maybe is
considering
I'm probably playing Knight H3
just defend
okay and keep the initiative going here
I really want to play Bishop E3
but maybe I should just develop like
Bishop D3
F4
one problem is now I can't Castle maybe
Knight F2 and then castling
I'll take that and
I think the Rook is now trapped
oh that defends
okay so I won a pawn
you did have to trade Queens there nice
to catch a live stream great content oh
thank you
hark here welcome back
enjoying the open D file inbox
underdeveloped and has some some issue
with the bishop
okay
some idea to hopefully trap the rook and
there's F6 so
not quite traveling The Rook
and there's a lot of ways to generate
more pressure here
like Knight c5's idea
yeah b5's coming
B5 I'm considering Knight C5
probably not necessary though
okay 96.
um probably Nexus takes and Knight G5
and I'm threatening the pawn that oh
defends
bring the rook in
all the pieces are pretty much optimized
but there's a question where's my tactic
something like F5
this is a camel and this is a straw
I still don't know what I'm threatening
though
like takes
and this
are we gonna see King takes wow
it's so close to meat
check
so maybe takes check check
still not seeing the meat
okay so I'm fighting this and this
a combination of like takes in 96.
oh my Rook is trapped
really
rook's not quite trapped nice move
though
opponent being resourceful
okay still threatening this
my G6 might be coming
so Knight takes Paul and I take on E6
oh
let's play this
yeah we're trading into some end game
foreign
material too
oops
okay
oh he fought very well there
ah
I thought it was going to be easier to
like crack at some points but
wasn't so simple it was Rick again
uh this game this was a um like
reverse-fired liver game I've only
played this and then D3 and Knight G4
and D4 is a move
okay so this is a line of the Petrov I
mean I wanted to be more aggressive
I still have to play reasonable moves
gee this is a nice kind of active way of
playing Bishop F5
uh maybe takes and
uh that was that was the wrong way to go
ah what did I do
Bishop G6 it's okay
this move might be coming
I have to kind of hunker down and just
make sure my King's not getting
checkmated
[Music]
I think it's okay now I'm losing a pawn
though
ah
this moon now
oh thank you Harker
okay I have 50 seconds two and a half
minutes and I'm down the pond
uh let's play this
this is a move so it takes takes
I'm just trying to make white think and
maybe have some shot at coming back on
time
not quite traveling The Rook
unfortunately
debating Rook D1
might make some sense
at least my king is a bit more active
light squares could be weak
yeah let's trade Rooks
and Rook D2
[Music]
generally when you're down material you
shouldn't trade but
going for activity here
two is not easy to defend
now the rook and pawner hits
now I hit the bishop and this Pawn
so Point gave me an early holiday gift
five
this still is not simple
yeah
a lot of play for white
man
I might lose this
it might be a draw actually
okay I'm playing for a win for some
reason
wow
what's going on here
crazy line look at the sign
King F1 and then Knight here wow
so King E1 right here I'm controlling
all these squares
not with the Rook but with the King and
Knight Rook b1's Unstoppable
oh it is stoppable
oops
it's still for his mate
wow
ah I thought it was Unstoppable
oh wow
yeah I miss rooked yate that was really
fortunate
what a finish that game
I mean white played really well it's
like fight back down the piece after
missing the bishop was hanging
okay
keep going
I beat this upon earlier
uh but this time I'm black
let's play a different opening
uh let's play C5 reverse Queen's Gambit
and then takes
and then E5 hey Eric you've mentioned on
stream that you meditate what does your
meditation I used to team look like and
what do you get out of it
um
I actually haven't like done
Focus meditation in a while
um but I used to use uh headspace and
waking up those were my like two
go-to meditation apps
a lot of it was like the simple five to
ten minute guided meditations
focused on
um mainly focus on like breathing
like paying attention to the breath
I do miss it I want to like return to
doing it consistently
okay I gotta I gotta move quicker here
it's hard to play with less time and
talk about something
a little bit unrelated
905 Bishop C5
play Rook E8
and B4 is coming
I mean G6 Bishop G7
this looks solid
there's about five of nine of three
wow Bishop G4 between C8
Let's Play Bishop C8
okay Center stays closed that's a good
practical decision from lights
and guaranteeing a long game
Bishop is better on H6 here
97 going after C4 B C5 I played B6
trying to provoke C5 there's this move
too
I go away with taking I think I do
oh I blundered
how bad is it though
and this software takes takes takes
there's rookie three
but maybe it's okay because B4 is coming
and I'm still controlling C1
[Music]
it looks very shaky though but I'm
threatening a triple Fork
let's go for this sign
Mass simplification
E5 should fall
the other thing involves it's all about
activity though
Rook C2
[Music]
on top I gotta orchestrate some mating
attack
maybe this 92 Knight of three
foreign
[Music]
there should be three coming
check
okay I'm winning Pawn back so it's Eagle
interior actually
just time situation is not great
draw
I want to draw
wow opponents like a draw
I was very low on time there
uh okay I guess I can't complain about
that
uh in first place the first draw of the
tournament
I do lose my streak for that but
I was in trouble that game so I'll take
it
hey it's Akash what's up bakash
hope you're doing well
uh let's play Joe Bava London for Akash
Akash had one of like the most insane
games
I think in New York I saw it on Twitter
it's like some crazy jobava London
where he sacked all his pieces and then
won
okay this is a slightly different line
wow
okay let's play this threatening some
Queen D5
this would be Seven's coming or that
move
okay focusing on developing first
I was so close to meeting
uh
uh played this first
as d6wear
if only this word bug house
okay so I'm hitting the bishop
let's play this
foreign
for everyone just joining this is uh
Eastern super Blitz arena in 90 minute
Blitz tournament I've essentially agreed
to play Super aggressively every single
game
so a mix of gambits and
just really aggressive openings
I've also been berserking a lot
um to add some spiciness
I play this move first
might as well and then take
I think we're just trading though
yeah we're just Trading
okay
end game approaching
three
I should probably play H4 although that
hangs upon
the pawn should be on dark squares and
not light squares
just with light squared Bishops
okay I can take
now it's Knight versus Bishop
love to play D4 although E5 is coming
first
I'm losing a pawn
don't see it okay opponent misses it
H4 was hanging there
I should have played D4 there and still
play D4 next
does this work
I think it's okay so I win B6
wow this is work
oh there's King D7
yeah
almost worked
take take
I'm in trouble
Rook d5i Fork
in big trouble here TimeWise
a little bit too slow there good game to
my opponents
oh okay
almost forgot what it's like to lose the
game
but uh it's okay still in first place
uh but not by much 43 points off my
streak
maybe I have to be more aggressive
to avoid getting into the end game
playing a berserk I mean berserk rate
has been a berserk performance has been
pretty good
playing a slav
I don't usually play this I don't know
why I'm playing this like
um a neo-grunfeld type thing
opponents playing Super aggressively
and I'm actually playing solidly
but I've okay maybe I want to play for
at some points
yeah I like the fact that lights
committed to each Pawn because it's
unlikely castling will happen which
means the king should be more of a
Target in the center
so maybe E5 at some point
and this Knight might move which means
my knight will have to move
and there's a line Knight T4 E5
which looks pretty good like takes and
then takes
okay White's going crazy
um
there's about E5 preventing my G4
and a G5
ideas of Knight B4
yeah this is pretty safe for black
not material and I think I have more
attacking potential
here we go
yeah this is where the initiative starts
D3 should be coming
uh yeah let's play D3
and queen maybe A4 first
takes and then Queen D5
oh can I second night
it looks fine I might as well do it
so the point is
I get a pawn and the file
King takes Queen D5 wins back the piece
Queen D5 anyway
of Night Moves I have E4
there's also B2 lingering like B2
threads made in one
a queen A2 is very hard to prevent
now there is King takes and then King C1
but I don't think white survives for too
much longer there like Rook CA
threatening Queen A1 mate
okay this this game was more aggressive
than some of the previous ones
oh it's still not me though
check check
this first
unleashing the bishop
yeah where's the meat
I'm not meeting
and there's still a raging attack even
with Queens off the board
time is pretty good too
uh yeah keep the Rooks connected
um
Now where's the mating idea
let's move threading this
oops
oops
I have this move
check
I'm losing in this final position or am
I
bring it all out
oh wow not expecting white to survive
that
but yeah it drains a lot of time for
like I guess figuring out how to survive
there
okay trying to rebuild a streak
playing this person who I drew earlier
they took the draw in like position
where they all grew up a ton of time
um let's play England Gambit okay let's
play whatever this is
of reverse French
reverse French
so White's winning upon
or not
obviously choose a threat
so how do I not lose a piece
it's my age six
each word was actually a very smart move
I was expecting this move which we do
see
let's take
yeah this is getting messy
and Knight D5 is a playable move
Bishop D2 I take on D4 and this is a
scary move
I mean queen D7
some idea to play Knight F4 Knight G2 or
Knight F4 Queen G5
maybe I could have played that first
yeah that breaks a pin so I have to move
back actually I don't have to move let's
play this
battery Square for the king
I want to bust open the center at some
points
not so easy though
now can I take
nah
play this
might be a queen F5
so f2's attacked and there's some
potential that I mean these squares are
guarded by Queen and Knight
foreign
so maybe it's a matter of deflecting
the E4 is coming
I mean I kind of get away with sacking
I don't think I can
there's a funny line E5 takes takes mate
oppon's gonna see it though
never mind
okay opponent didn't see the funny line
those are cool mates
that's a nice mating pattern
okay the in-between move Save the Day
yeah I was probably like much worse the
whole game until
the final move
if White had played Queen D4 yeah just
take the Knight with a queen
probably would have been in trouble
so far a lot of the risks paying off
I'm sticking with E4
uh let's play a Tennyson
a tennis and Gamma time
Knight G5 and D3
if H6 it's a funny trap
if E5 is also a funny trap
Bishop G4 I don't think I've seen before
[Music]
wow
I take on F7 it's a funny line
I have no idea if this works
let's try it
so I'm counter-attacking the queen
and if takes takes it's a queen train
b7's hanging if King takes and I get the
classic tennis and Ganda tactic
and I guess if King d8 we just trade
Queens but I have a better position
Bishop pair and better structure
all the funny opening
I've never seen Bishops before in the
Tennis Center
okay so I'll still try and play
aggressively even though this is
like kind of just a queenless middle
game
there's opportunity to
uh to try and attack against the pawns
King
or at least place the pieces on more
aggressive squares
I promise E5 is coming
start with 95 94
preparing the pawn advance
that's a good move
to cover the squares
C4 now comes
ah
giving back the bishop hair
the good thing is after night of 6
Knight C3
E4 is reinforced
and if we trade then the Knight can't
really be touched
though I allowed this move
opponent misses it
Bishop D4 would have been really
annoying
uh
okay that's nice to see
um let's play this
still takes a lot of work here
I'm not sure where my breakthrough is
threading this
there we go
why'd I do that I thought Rook T8 would
be me and it's not meat
I'm in big trouble here
I think black just misfortunate
there's Rook H1 Bishop H4 rookie two
okay not the highest quality game
but still somehow holding on
that's a great move
try and activate the king
oh dear
did I move quicker
okay I I held on for a draw
was there a free rook
oh that was just a free rook
why did I play Knight B5 wait what was I
even thinking why did Black just not
take
I think what happened I was assuming
King these man there were so many things
missed on so many levels King C7 was
played
for some reason I was expecting King D7
and I wanted to just repeat to be funny
but
yeah that was just a free rook oh dear
hallucinations happening
so this person's on my channel this is a
person who beat me the first round
and they're on a streak this could be a
close finish
oh this person beat me okay let me try
and get revenge
in Budapest let's play this benoni
maybe I can play a Blumenfeld
or maybe
yeah let's play this line against London
this is a nice aggressive line
it does enter some early Queen trade but
it can wind up with that getting some
nice initiative or if Knight here I just
play Queen C7
Ah that's a move in D5
okay
now I'm trying to get this like
well-known structure
which I think we're achieving yeah
basically the structure and later go for
B5 B4
Quincy it's very typical to
allow the b-pawn to move
B4 should be coming
[Music]
E6 tries to to reinforce things E5 Queen
E7
the board could be split and then I mean
I'll be playing on the queen side white
will be playing on the king side
MP3 at some points
I like my prospects here
and queen B7 so I want to take over the
a file and the way to do that is like
this
now the Knight wants to come to A4 so
this is probably the maneuver
like B2 is uh the main target here
now the question is each seven week
yeah it might still a little bit slow to
attack H7
maybe I'll go for Rook A1
try and infiltrate with a queen
that doesn't do much
okay going after the pawn
Queen D2 probably coming or that move
okay so this Pawn is pinned to the king
I want to play this move
not easy to crack
the queen might want to come back around
[Music]
uh six
look at this move Queen G8
so F6 is a fork but I play king f8 with
a discover check
and I save the bishop
what a crazy position
[Music]
can I sack
all lights winning the thing
after sack
what's going on here
wow just in time
I don't know how this turned in my favor
okay what a crazy game
oh that was insane
I mean this this structure is just crazy
like we both had connect five
and then somehow I mean it looked like
white was just winning the pond I don't
know my Prime stop and then the only
like idea was to suck at peace
I was down a piece here but the bishop
just it literally just scooped up all
the Pawns
and the Queen
okay
I'll take it
oh it's close
playing this person again
uh what can I play Let's go back to this
opening
I don't mind this either
I have six
yeah I think this is already like very
pleasant for
black
I want to play F5 but then the queen D5
check
um
okay
so allowing Bishop takes H6
okay now we got a nice aggressive
position
[Music]
I don't want to lose a bishop
might have to though
get this move
okay I save the bishop
I think I'll go for this it's a pawn
sack
ideas to get the queen in
and maybe went back the pond F3 is not
legal
Bishop E2
oh there's this move too
and I take and we trade Queens
doesn't look so bad
I think there should be Two's A Move
I have three I have to play Queen d8
trade
um
so Queen's Garden E7
I didn't want to allow the exchange sack
it's a little bit annoying but
D6 is also weak but I have not a Saturn
thing for you
down a minute
so attacking wires I still want to
open things up on the king side
like King HH Rook gh5
he's seven randomly hanging
B7 also hanging
but the Knight found a happy place
okay yeah this is where I go For Broke
or just take a free Queen
okay uh now I just have to not flag
oh what's my idea
we need seven
and Knight B7 holy Lou
[Music]
going for Queen C5
Rook B6 High fourth of rook and
King
Christmas has come early this game
I hope
okay
that's a nice gift
back on a streak
trying to create some separation
between second place
uh let's play D4
mix up things a little bit
this is I believe the Stein has Gambit
or bronstein I forgot the name of this
dolly grob
play E6
threatening made in three
opponent of course sees it
does
this work I sack a bishop oh no my
Bishop
[Music]
um
this looks so much fun
okay I missed a fork but
it's still okay
B4
and the queen is like wait is there
mates I just win the queen
and light will return
to finish unvis unfinished business
that was a fun little opening there
I guess uh King C8 Bishop F7
and this Pawn can't be defended
nice dork a dork the discovered Fork
he had discovered Fork thanks uh things
Black Goose
okay my queen hasn't moved this game
Let's Make a Move of the queen
no mercy
no mercy look at the sixth rank
it's almost occupied hey I occupied the
six rank
okay
that was a nice finish
oh Grand Master in top 10 looks like
they Lee joined
berserk winning a lot of games
so we're in the final lesson nine
minutes now
yeah there's been a lot of thumbnail
worthy positions this stream
to figure out the best thumbnail-worthy
position
[Music]
uh playing this opponent oh we drew
earlier
ah that Rook ending
okay let's play England Gambit
oh
uh let's play Reverse BlackMart Deemer
okay this is like a reverse wrench
now I don't know what this is
but I like it
H3 may be coming
and preventing Knight F4
of
like Bishop D6 and then 97
I'm gonna play B5
okay I can't complain with this I mean
gaining space on all areas of the board
it started as a Gambit
and now we're here
an idea to get the C file
if I move the Knight I'll allow Queen C6
you know white is a little bit smushed
if castling I pin
okay I'll play A5
uh
Queen
I don't want to uh lose a pawn like The
Rook has to say on h8
to defend
yeah that's a slightly annoying move
maybe keemy seven
defend with the King
I just want to trade off White's only
active piece
uh
I take
see this move
some idea of Rook C8
almost trapping the queen
going after the bee Pawn
so it's not so simple I should have
played A4 first there
but this is looking good threading oh
let's play this
still threatening Rook B1
not too many ways to defend
oh my Rook
uh I actually blundered their Rook
because my taste B4
I think opponent trusted me though I
play this move don't my knight
okay it's winning now
I honestly thought I was being so genius
takes and I thought this was mating that
Knight takes before
I think my opponent just thought the
same thing that they were scared of this
and made the square for the king
so the bluff kind of worked it wasn't
even supposed to be a bluff
anti-bluff
or a failed love
oh no my oh no my acting
okay time for at least one more game
hopefully
not gonna play the GM there they just
started in a new game
this person I could play this person no
I'm playing this person
I'll play E4 this game
oh let's um mix up the opening I already
played the Tennyson
ah what is this
I'm gonna play Joe Bava London
oh okay this is some funny trap
is it winning though
2012
I think I'm winning a pawn here
I might just want to torture the Knight
before I take out okay maybe not
now I'm threatening this and this
and even this because takes Knight C7
uh
ah where's the
not have anything
before
I don't think I have anything
I guess I'll play before no
I'll just play this I'll just develop
maybe yeah I should have played Knight
C7
I don't know
I still should have played Knight C7
okay because I have 96 which wins some
material
foreign
41 seconds no Queen trade
okay and The Rook wants to get involved
Pawn is hanging tagging the bishop
idea 95
F3
and Bishop B5
and the main goal is to make this game
count for the tournaments
the Knight is practically trapped
there's 97 then I take whatever it takes
back there's a Pinner skewer
oh if I take this queen G3 very clever
um
Kim G2 kingna Rook G2
rookie two
preparing Rook G2
I have 15 seconds left
this game might not count for the
tournament
uh check
22 seconds left in the tournament
is really close
oops
ah okay are you just try and win the
game now
where's the force meat
two seconds left
uh
uh yeah that was my scheme
back to tournaments
got some confetti
got some more confetti
that was fun I hope people enjoyed that
got some crazy games some really dirty
games I tried to play aggressively
there's some games that call for
um all for end game technique or
positional play but uh had some fun if
this goes on YouTube uh let me know in
the comments your favorite game in the
video
I'll time stamp every single game
in the description it should form his
chapters
if you're also watching on YouTube
don't forget to subscribe I'm close to
600 000 subscribers
uh maybe like three or 4K away at this
point
and if you're watching on Twitch
um also don't forget to subscribe on
YouTube and or twitch oh no my ability
for the bitrate to render my access
detail on stream